we have a terrific show tonight excuse
me conan
sorry who was that oh hey i'm really
sorry boss i know you got a show to do
here
but i just wanted to say i heard about
you wrapping things up here at tbs after
11 great years
congratulations well thank you yeah
that's right we're uh
going to be wrapping up this iteration
of the show in june and
the plan is to re-emerge on hbo mac
sometime in the near future so
yeah it's a it's a change but it's
pretty exciting but still
we had a hell of a run right boss so
many memories
i'm gonna miss this place yeah listen i
don't mean to offend you and
maybe it's just because of the low
lighting or something but i don't
recognize you
at all i'm sorry how long have you been
with our show
god how long i guess it's been g since 9
22 am
9 22 this morning plus or minus
i'm supposed to be in at 9 but i was
listening to stern in my truck and he
was really going off on asian pete
sorry i was late wait i'm sorry you're
saying this is your first day here
at my last i'm just stepping in today
for donnie because last night
he had a little too much of the old
cocaine if you know what i mean
yeah i think it just means he had
cocaine yeah we all know what you mean
anyways so many memories like trying to
find parking at the theater
then finally finding parking at the
theater taking my lunch break
then interrupting you just a few minutes
ago
and finally writing my juicy tell-on
memoir about my time on the show
there's a whole chapter in there about
your toilet noises
okay
you're fired you you gotta go that's
fine i know how to work this dump thing
anyway
so long and thanks for the longest job
i've ever had
despite what you saw we've got a great
show michelle bouteau is going to be
joining us
we'll take a break we'll be right back
i'm going to miss that guy andy he's
been here in less than a day
yeah but he really i don't know it feels
like family